[Müzik]
Anna Bob ve karla üç çocuk ve sadece bir
flüt var
Sizce bu flüt kimin olmalı
Anna flütü en iyi çalabilen olduğunu
söylüyor bobise Çok yoksul bir çocukluk
geçirdiğini söylüyor ve hiçbir
oyuncağının olmadığını söylüyor karla
ise aylarca Emek vererek bu flütü
kendisinin imal ettiğini söylüyor
ananın flütü çok iyi çalabildiği babamın
yoksul bir çocuk olduğu
tarlanınsa bu flütü imal ettiği kendi
içlerinde kabul ettikleri bir gerçek
Peki katî bir yetkiye sahip olan lider
siz olsaydınız flütü kime verirdiniz
Nobel ödüllü Hindistanlı
iktisatçı amarteyken senin bir Idiots
kitabında bahsettiği geçen hikayede üç
çocuk bir flüt adlı hikayede Aslında
lider olarak verdiğiniz kararda doğru ya
da yanlış yok Sadece tercihler var
liderleri Lider yapan tercihleridir
tercihler kararlar seçimler
iş hayatıma ilk başladığında liderliğin
birinci tarzı diye geçen söyleyen ve
yaptıran liderlikle tanışmıştım Aslında
sunumdan önce de Dışarıda birkaç kişiyle
sohbet ettim dışarıda güvenliğimizden
sorumlu Barış Bey ile konuştum Lider net
olacak abi dedi Tam da bu aşama söyleyen
ve yaptır anneyi der
her şeyi hakimsin aslında biraz da
sanayi devrimi gibi bir şey üretiyorsun
ve satıyorsun üretiyorsun satıyorsun
lider var söylüyor Lider dediğim bu
arada babam şirket dediğinde aile
şirketimiz söylüyor Bunlar yapılacak ve
yapılıyor o zaman ürün gamları da biraz
az olduğu için Aslında çok fazla düşünme
süreci yok ama burada motivasyon çok az
sadece iş yapıp evinize gidip
yatıyorsunuz kendinizi bir çalışan
olarak düşündüğünüzde bir sonraki aşama
işler biraz daha komplikeleştiğinde
fikrinizi pazarlamanız lazım ekibinize
Fikri pazarlayarak Fikri empozyeden
Lider bir oda düşünün odanın
tasarlanması lazım Lider size
Bence bu odada mavi Masalar kullansak
çok güzel olur diyor
fazla da fikrinizi alınıyor burada
motivasyon biraz daha yüksek çünkü Bence
kelimesini kullanıyor
Danışan Lider kısmı size fikrini soruyor
ama çok fazla Es vermeden Bu odanın
tasarlanması lazım diyor yine aynı
şekilde şöyle daha güzel oldu diyor Eve
gittiğinizde uyuduğunuzda düşünüyorsunuz
acaba Benim dün bahsettiğim Fikri
danışılan kişi olarak ben benim
söylediklerim dikkate alınacak mı
diyorsunuz sabah geldiğinizde O da zaten
çoktan tasarlanmış oluyor
yetki devre ve delegasyon kısmına
geldiğimde artık şirketin
yönetimindeydim Bunu geliştirmek için
yapmam gereken çalışmalar vardı
bunun birkaç örneğini gördüm umursamaz
Yetki devri yapan çok kısa da olsa
Amerika'da ufak çalıştığım bir dönemde
bana şöyle bir önerge verilmişti bu
havuz tüm kimyasallarıyla tüm
organizasyonda Yarın sabah hazır olmalı
dedi ve gitti süpervizitrerim arıyorsun
ulaşamıyorsun Çünkü seni gözlemleyen bir
lider yok Peki sizce ertesi gün o havuz
hazır mıydı Evet hazırdı ama büyük bir
stres yaşadım Gece boyunca Çünkü ulaşıp
tanışabileceğim bir lider yok umursamaz
deligasyon ekipte büyük bir baskı
yaratıyor ama kendi içini keşfetmesi
açısından da bir avantaj sağlıyor diğer
kısım ise güçlendiren deligasyon
ekibinizi güçlendirdiğinizde
yetkinliklerini sağladığınızda
çok daha zaman kazanıyorsunuz Aslında
şimdi bunu çok duyuyorum burada Kurumsal
firmalarda çalışan arkadaşlar da vardır
şöyle bir hikaye vardı Geçtiğimiz
günlerde büyük bir firma eğitim yapıyor
arkadaşımla konuşuyoruz ama bizim firma
eğitim yapıyor Ne kadar güzel 2 milyon
lira bütçe ayırmışlar bir hafta sonra
Evet biz 300 kişiyiz Evet Hani eğitim
yerine onu bizim maaşımıza ekleseler bu
büyük bir hata Çünkü aslında burada
kazan kazan ilişkisi var firmanız Sizi
yetkinleştirerek Aslında primlerim
bölümlerin gelişmesini sağlıyor ve
Aslında o yetkiyi size verdiğinde daha
rahat üst kademenin daha kritik kararlar
alması için zaman kazanmasını sağlıyor
bunlara yatırım yapmanız Önem vermeniz
Aslında büyük bir cümle Ama gerçekten
ulusal gelişimimize fayda sağlayan bir
konu Çünkü Sizler geliştiğinizde birçok
insan şunu unutuyor çalıştığı firmalarda
ben buraya ne kadar katkı sağlayabilirim
özellikle çok büyük firmalarda gerçekten
sağlayabileceğinize inanmanız lazım
Dediğim gibi Kazan kazanın ilişkisi
Belki oradaki yönetici şahsi olarak
senin gelişmen çok istiyorum diye
arzuluyor olabilir ama diğer yandan da
tamamen kendini düşünüyor firmanın
kollarının birimlerinin iyi bir şekilde
çalışmasını hedefliyor
mükemmel makinist bir tren düşünelim
eski buharlı bir tren mat siyah bir renk
dosdoğru çok lüks bir tren
treni adımınızı atıyorsunuz sizi biri
karşılıyor makinist adınızı biliyor
hobilerinizi biliyor sizi çok iyi
çalışmış iyi bir makinesin treni idare
eden kişi Normalde
odanıza çekiliyorsunuz
kompartımanındasınız Yatağın üstünde bir
not bu yatak sizin için özellikle
hazırlanmıştır temizlenmiştir diye bir
not düşünmeye başlıyorsunuz Aslında tren
çok kalabalık Sadece size mi bu ilgisi
Neyse diyorsunuz restorana geçiyorsunuz
restoranda garsonu kesiyorsunuz
bir yerden tanıdık geliyor Evet
bu sefer korkmaya başlıyorsunuz Çünkü
tren hareket etmeye başladı
trenin belli noktalarda yavaşlaması Ray
değişimlerini takip etmesi lazım kafada
bunları kuruyorsunuz eski bir tren
merakınız da var buhar odasına
gidiyorsunuz kazanı görmeye kan ter
içinde bir kişi kömür atıyor fırına bu
sefer canavarıyla koşarak lokomotife
gidiyorsunuz bir bakıyorsunuz ki kimse
yok içeride Çünkü makinesiyle orada
Tam siz oradayken bir omzunuza çarpıp
içeri giriyor makinist
trenin yavaşlatıyor Ray değişimini
yakalıyor
Bugün de atlattık diyor
mükemmel makinesi örneğinde çok fazla
dezavantajlar var aslında bir büyük bir
zaman kaybı iki her işi kendisi yaptığı
için arkasından yetişecek bir ekip yok
ve yolcuların yerine ekip çalışanlar
olarak kendinizi koyduğunuzda büyük bir
stres Biz nereye gidiyoruz bizi kim
İdare ediyor
delegasyonu ve yetki devrimin önemi
zamandan bağımsız bir şekilde liderin
hem arkadan gelecek olan ekibin
yetişmesine faydası sağlamasında hem de
kendisinin daha kritik kararlar alması
için zaman kazanmasında Büyük bir rol
alıyor delegasyon yetkili devre
bu terimi bilenler var mı
param Master Şef çok moda
lüks bir restoran düşünün ve bunun
mutfağını düşünün çok kalabalık Herkes
çalışıyor Herkes bir yemek yetiştirmeye
çalışıyor
yemekler tamamlandıktan sonra o yemek
acıysa acının tadının daha iyi
alabilmeniz için biraz tattıysa ona bir
kat vermek için bu misket limonunu
kabuğundan biraz içine rendeler ve bunu
suyu Şef falan yapmaz sadece ana Şef
yapar
bu yetki devrimden bu kadar bahsetmişken
Aslında lider olarak sizlerin de
ekiplerinizin çalışmalarını lezzet
katmanız bir açıdan da imza atmanız çok
değerli ve kıymetli lider olarak hem bu
hazzı yaşamanız hem de bu yol
göstericiliği yapmanız gerekir
harca coğrafyada liderlik Aslında şöyle
bir konu var
dünyanın en ücra köşesinde bir kabile
düşünün Orada bile Yetki devri liderlik
var
Hadi ava çıkalım Bir dakika bir bilgiye
soralım Bugün hava nasıl hadi yemek
yiyelim durun biri hastalandı şifacınıza
götürelim güçlüler ava gitsin güçsüzler
ot toplasın
burada bahsi geçen Güçlü kelimesi
Aslında çok kritik
Çünkü Lider dikkat ettiyseniz güçlüler
insanın en temel ihtiyacı olan karnını
doyurma hissiyatı ihtiyacı daha doğrusu
Lider burada risk almıyor Az önce
bahsettiğim gibi büyük firmaların
yöneticilerin de sizlerin gelişmesi güç
Orada aslında gelişme hedefliyor
ekiminizi geliştirmenin önemi bu konuya
dayanıyor
bununla alakalı Aslında yıllarca
başarıyı konuştuk
bayağı bir yıldır da liderliği
konuşuyoruz Çevik liderlik
kavrayıcıl liderlik zor dönemde liderlik
Özellikle pandemi de çıktı krizde
liderlik Google'dan milyonlarca şey
bulabilirsiniz onlardan bahsetmeyeceğim
dolanan bilgiler arasında liderin
özellikleri
tane özellik sıralamışlar 100 tane Lider
özelliği peki sizce bunlardan kaç tanesi
doğuştan gelen özellik herhangi bir
fikri
sadece iki tanesi değerli dostlar
bir tanesi karizma bir tanesi IQ Onun da
öyle olduğu düşünülüyor sadece onun için
gelişiminize her zaman Önem vermeniz
Aslında liderlik Sonradan öğrenilebilen
bir kısım Çünkü %98'i öğrenilebiliyor
kabileden biraz daha farklı bir sisteme
geçerim
Bu Son zamanda çok fazla dijital
dünyalarla alakalı filmler izledim
orada konu ve filmler hep şöyle bitiyor
Bir düzen var Birisi sistemi kurmuş
sabah uyanıyorsun gözlüğünü takıyorsun
ya orada çalışıyorsun ya başka bir iş
yapıyorsun ya da oyun oynayıp para
kazanıyorsun ama her sistem birisi
çıkıyor günün sonunda diyor ki; ben bu
oyunu bozarım Neden Çünkü her devrin bir
Tatar Ramazan'ı var
Duygu birliğiyle insanlar bu sistemleri
bozuyor hep bir araya geliyorlar Çünkü
otonom sistemden sıkılıyorlar Evet
yönetici sistemleri orada geliştiriliyor
farklı karar algoritmaları var otonom
düzenler var yalnız Duygu birliğini
yakalayamadığınız hiçbir sistemde
Sürdürülebilir liderliği elde
edemezsiniz
bu Kişiyi tanıyan var mı
ihtiyaçlar hiyer aşısında
mutluluğu araştırmıştır
insanların mutluluğunu ve en alt
kademede temel ihtiyaçlar yeter
onun hemen üstünde güven duygusu
karşılıklı güvene dayanan bir duygu ve
yukarıya doğru çıktığınızda Aslında
yaşadığın yakaladığınız değer kendini
gerçekleştirme kendini ispatlama
kanıtlama
yeter insanların yeteneklerini
desteklediğinizde bu piramitte o
yolculuğa fırsat vermeniz gerekiyor yine
zamandan bahsediyorum Çünkü biz burada
geleceğin liderliğini liderliğinin yeni
şeklini Konuşuyoruz Ondan bağımsız bir
şekilde liderliği konuşuyorsak Eğer
insanların ihtiyaçlarını ne kadar
gözettiğimiz devreye giriyor
yarına da ayrı bir liderlik konuşuyoruz
bugün bugün de insanlarıyla
zamandan bağımsız olacak tek şey
duygular insanların motivasyonları
Yarın geçerli olan tek şey Yarın
karşımıza çıkacak değişime hazır
Olmaktır aslında
lideri olabileceğiniz her durumu
ailenizin Eşinizin dostunuzun firmanızın
lideri olacağınız her durumun içerisinde
insanlar belirli bir olgunluğa
geldiğinde onlara Yetki devri vermeyi
hatırlamanız Sürdürülebilir bir liderlik
sağlıyor ve temel ihtiyaçlarının
karşılanmasını
liderlik yolculuğunda
Zor kararlar alırken
insanların duygularını
duygularına da çok fazla Duygu dedim ama
duygulara dokunmanızda gerçekten ilham
verici birisi olabilir sizin için ama
sizin için lider olmaz insanların
duygularına dokunmanız lazım Zor
kararlar alacağınızda geleceği
göğüsleyecek bir şekilde İnsanların
hayatına dokunmanız gerekiyor
flütün kimin olması gerektiği gibi zor
konularda bile teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]